right there yeah what's up guys watching
Bert's we got a coronavirus debate club
for you it's okay that we wear the mask
put the kids doll and we got a cat
around here somewhere
should we put a mask on the cat and
he'll I mean their kids is gonna be a
serial killer
surely that dudes gonna kill it's a new
family that kid's gonna kill and like
five of those cats point yes she's so
he's back there going why so serious to
the point though it is a Boomer virus I
know people hate to hear that but it's
taking out the Boomers no kids that fast
well it's taking out Trump voters too
that's another thing it's taking on
don't hide in butters your fan base yeah
that's a good question what do you guys
think mass on the just the adults are
the kids listen dude you didn't make
more kids
save yourself this coming from a new
father this from the guy who's like yeah
I loaded up on stuff or no beef jerky oh
the good stuff
Wow since you're saying just mass on the
adults-only yeah well do when they say
like if the oxygen level of the plane
air pressure goes the mask you know put
it on yourself though first don't worry
about the kids if you actually like them
there's a lot of parents out there
freaking out that they got to hang out
with their kids all day and the kids the
kids don't understand what's going on
there's no you know what I suggest
[ __ ] sit your kids down you're
getting sick of them sit him down scare
the [ __ ] out of them with contagion put
that movie Contagion
outbreak scare the [ __ ] out of them and
then [ __ ] tell him you got a
quarantine lock them in their room yeah
you got it we got a quarantine
everyone's got it corns you go dad how
long a couple weeks we got a
bringing food [ __ ] lock them in there
no boom yeah I'm with that connote you
know in LA do some messages every now
and then in Vietnamese you give them
their [ __ ] there i Cheerios and [ __ ]
in a hazmat suit just like PO you got to
stay in your room the door make a prison
lockup still understand deal we're gonna
shut down shut down till September
September dude that said May now you
want September I know I [ __ ] up yeah
who do you work for
no dude a lot of bad news coming up in
every year September hey dude everybody
knows you were learning through your son
a little bit weed mushrooms stuck inside
for a couple weeks scared of the krona
what's he's on all of them yeah he said
all of the above d all the above ah I
don't need more panic I don't take
mushrooms and start freaking the [ __ ]
out watching what was the last time you
did shroom yeah it's a good question
three four years ago i micro dose and
did hot yoga and just stared at the yoga
instructors asked for the entire hour
even though they told me to stop really
yeah we go please out the front big boy
mm-hmm
I just stayed in one position for the
time that microdose and people use that
effectively oh yeah I've never in my
career you know what I've taken a couple
stems I guess you can call that micro
dosing but the real trip on mushrooms
though is five grams that's the real
traumatic for that that's what Terence
Mckenna
says that don't do eyes Hey that's that
that's like a DMT trip you do five grams
put it in a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich boom I've done deal I've done
DMT I love peanut butter Lee I didn't
hit the [ __ ] zoo
freak the [ __ ] did he at the zoo I know
five grams why would you do mushrooms I
do I wasn't no I'm not a muscle I
thought it was a great idea let's go to
the zoo check out the animals
by the painters but then right when it
hits dude like oh my god all these
animals are [ __ ] depressed they're in
jail and then you just want to run I
just want her to run out of the plugin
and I'm disabled Tiger jumping I was
[ __ ] up dude that was the wrong place
to be Zoo is the last place you want to
be the monkeys look like there were just
suicide were you with your family no I
was with your boyfriend that's the way
to do with a female okay I went to the
world of Spira I would use about right
dad you're like those are the friend
Eddie what about this so did the animals
did you feel like a relationship to the
animals like did you feel like it yes I
made eye contact like oh this
[ __ ] feels our pain
he's like oh I do feel your [ __ ]
there's a polar bear they gotta do their
polar bear exhibit is like built in 1920
or something dude it's like this white
[ __ ] supposed to be like an iceberg
and there's a white door where the guys
come out to feed the polar bear yeah and
that polar bear was just pacing back by
that door back and forth would not stop
just pacing back they go insane like
that yeah that's a sign of them losing
their mind but did you feel like we were
from animals more do you feel like we're
related to each other at all I thought
there I felt like oh [ __ ] they're all
unlike the rats bad I don't need to
dream that Noah's Ark America's largest
water park then how'd that go it was the
best day of my life did you take your
trunks off nope kept them on I did rooms
at the World Series which was in which
series uh when the Dodgers got [ __ ] by
the Astro the cheating ass Astros I did
this during one time at this dude
Lonnie's party and uh and I think I've
told the story I gave him out to
everybody then we played
hide-and-go-seek and people had never
done it before so like 30 people ate him
for the first time started a game of
hide-and-go-seek and didn't see him
nobody found some people never never
seen
let's live never seen relevant this is
the good old days
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]